let's get into it it was
eight years ago nine seasons ago that
russell wilson became a member of the
seattle seahawks there's plenty of talk
regarding whether or not he will finish
his career in seattle he claims to want
to play until he's 45.
some stuff has emerged in recent days
sunday one of the super bowl sunday
splash reports shireen
the seahawks getting phone calls about
the availability of russell wilson
seahawks say he's not available a report
from monday night jason lochen four of
cbs sports
russell wilson's camp is frustrated with
the lack of blocking that wilson gets
and the situation bears serious
monitoring or something ominous like
that
there's something going on
but
look time will tell how it all plays out
earlier today russell wilson on peacock
on the dan patrick show here he is we're
going to play some of what he said for
starters here's wilson talking about
his desire to be more involved in the
team's personnel decisions
how much input should the quarterback
have in
organizational moves veteran
quarterback yeah i think it depends on
who it is you know i think well how
about you how much do you have any say
in what seattle does offensively with
free agents or draft draft picks
uh
uh i think that it's uh
you know i think that ultimately for me
personally i you know i think that i
want to be able to be involved because
at the end of the day it's your legacy
it's your team's legacy it's you know
it's the guys you get to go into the
huddle with that's a long-winded way of
not answering my question are you
involved in personnel decisions have you
been involved in personnel decisions
not not as much i don't you know i think
that uh you know do you want to be
involved russ yeah i think it helps i
think it helps to be involved more
but i think that's that dialogue should
happen more often
look i've said this time and again as it
relates to all quarterbacks the coaching
staff in the front office and ownership
want the quarterback to be a quasi
member of management uh a boss on the
shop floor
setting the example showing up early
staying late motivating inspiring
holding accountable it's so much better
coming from the quarterback and then
when it's time to have the management
meeting oh sorry sorry
supervisors only you're just one of the
employees that doesn't fly especially
with the best quarterbacks and now and
we've been on to this
now that tom brady has shown what
happens when the front office and the
coaching staff say hey fine we'll get
whoever you want
some of these other great quarterbacks
that are jostling to get to number two
in the way of super bowl wins russell
wilson aaron rodgers patrick mahomes
i think they're going to start
start
pushing a little bit harder for some of
the power that management in tampa gave
to tom brady sheree
yeah mike and you started this and you
were the first one on it we were texting
back and forth the group on the pft
chain of who the quarterbacks are that
can do this and russell wilson certainly
is one of those i don't think anybody
would argue with that that he's a
franchise quarterback who should dictate
at least a little bit who the personnel
is at least on offense he can encourage
some guys to come to seattle there's no
doubt about that he can encourage them
possibly to take less money to come to
seattle so why wouldn't you want a guy
like russell wilson involved in some of
these decisions you would think that he
would be much happier playing there and
and more willing to do what it takes to
win not that he's not doing that now but
he would have more of an invested
interest in what they're doing mike
prime example antonio brown remember we
heard stories rumors reports about the
possibility of the seahawks adding
antonio brown that was russell wilson
and so tom brady gets the guy he wants
and what happens antonio brown catches a
touchdown pass in the super bowl yeah
according to clyde christensen he ran
the wrong route but still he won a super
bowl with tom brady and i'm not saying
that antonio brown would have been the
difference maker for the seahawks but
it's the idea of you're going to listen
to the quarterback or you're not and if
you don't
the quarterback
eventually is going to start thinking
maybe i need to go somewhere well they
will listen to me the tom brady example
he came from new england patriot way do
your job do your expletive deleted job
it's not your job as the quarterback to
determine who the players are do your
job tom 20 years of that gets old one
year of it in tampa and look at what
happens for tom brady so with all that
said
here's russell wilson from the dan
patrick show on the question of whether
or not he is available
for a trade
what do you make of uh cbs jason locke
and forrest saying that seattle had
gotten you know calls for uh possible
you know
trade talks with you do you believe that
that uh seattle has gotten calls
yeah i definitely believe they've gotten
calls for sure i didn't think that uh
you know i think anytime you're um you
know
you know a player that you know tries to
produce every week and has done it for
you know consistently i think people are
going to call for sure and i think it's
part of the process yeah but you're a
franchise quarterback you're a hall of
fame quarterback you're not available
are you
well i'm not sure if i'm available or
not that's a that's a ceo's question
hey look
uh
there's a belief in some league circles
that eventually russell wilson will play
for another team and here's how it's
going to go down this year
i'd be stunned if it happens pre-june 1.
if it happens pre-june 1 shireen the
seahawks take a 39 million
cap charge and this is one of those
years where you don't have to do it
before june 1. if there's not going to
be an off season program who cares do
the trade after june 1. if there's a
team out there that decides they really
want russell wilson but where this is
going to hit critical mass is the next
time wilson's agent mark rogers begins
negotiating another contract for russell
wilson because every time that wilson
has done an extension what's happened
he's gotten to the top of the market
he's gotten to the top of the market
he's gotten to the top well i can't say
it three times because he's only done it
twice the next time he's going to want
to get to the top of the market at some
point the amount of money that russell
wilson wants is going to be so much the
zx is going to say
nope too much
we can't justify paying that much to
russell wilson and that's when they go
back and they find a rookie who
makes very little and they can use all
they create the legion of boom with a
new round of players who get paid a lot
of money however that plays out i think
that's the pressure point and i think
that comes next year not this year i
think we got one more year before we're
either going to have another major
contract for russell wilson or he's
going to be traded yeah i'm with you
mike i i think this is a key season for
him and a key season for the seahawks to
see what they do you know in his second
season they go they win the super bowl
in 2013 they come back in 2014 and they
get to the super bowl and they lose the
super bowl he's five and one uh in those
two seasons that frankly we all know
they should have won that super bowl
they should have had back-to-back
championships it didn't work out uh
because of the interception there on the
goal line for the seahawks and they've
never seemed to recover from that
they're three and five in the postseason
since then that loss seemed to take a
lot of juice out of them and so they
need to figure out how to get russell
wilson back to the super bowl this year
it's not going to be easy with the
salary cap going down
but they need to figure it out whatever
it is or i see him as you do leaving
after this year and going somewhere else
it is an amazing time in this league
right now we've never seen this before
mike you saw quarterbacks go to one
place and stay forever that's not the
way it is anymore
and i think as more and more are having
success elsewhere specifically tom brady
it's beginning to spread and
quarterbacks are willing and here's the
thing that's kept it from happening in
the past
i think that quarterbacks have refrained
from even starting down that path
verbally for fear of becoming
an enemy
within their fan base
and 10 years ago five years ago i don't
think you hear a quarterback be as
candid as russell wilson was being
he's being pretty candid aaron rodgers
has stayed away from that line because i
think one of the things he doesn't want
to become is a pariah like brett favre
was i think that if and when there is a
separation between rogers and the
packers rogers wants to position it as
it was them not me i wanted to stay
once you start talking like maybe you
want to go somewhere else and wilson's
very diplomatic it's not like he said
trademe
but there's enough there he's getting
close to that line he's getting close to
that third rail that's where it becomes
potentially problematic but i think
we're going to see more quarterbacks
willing to do it because ultimately
these guys want to win and this is one
of my complaints about matthew stafford
12 years in detroit and he put up with
it
there's an item
from carlos monres of the detroit free
press i've been meaning to write about
it at pft it's trapped behind a paywall
but i got myself a copy of it
monterez basically said hey in 12 years
i never saw a desire for greatness from
matthew stafford and that's one of the
things i've been saying look
if you're not saying we got to get
better we got to get better we got to
get better if you're just like hey i
work here
you're part of the problem and you could
argue matthew stafford's been part of
the problem in detroit because he didn't
have that burning desire to win the
great ones have the burning desire to
win shireen
well and here's the other thing mike if
you go somewhere else you have far more
power than where you are so tom brady
didn't have that power in new england
but before he signed with tampa i'm sure
he said hey i want to bring some guys
with me i want to do it my way i want to
show these guys how to win in the box
we've won one super bowl in their
history and not since 2002 we're all in
whatever you want tom come sign with us
and we'll let you do whatever that's the
way it is when you go somewhere else
that's the way it is for anybody in
almost any business when you go
somewhere else and you've been really
good with where you are you have a lot
more say at the second site that you go
to mike
wilson also
said that he is frustrated with getting
hit too much that was the guts of what
jason lock and fora
reported on monday night i think it's
more
than the offensive line issues i think
it's the offense i think it's the team i
think it's everything that he looks
around and sees with the seahawks team
that hasn't been good enough to get past
the divisional round since 2014. yes the
last time they went to the super bowl is
the last time they made it out of the
divisional round and these quarterbacks
are confident to the point of delusional
all professional athletes are
russell wilson isn't going to say it's
on me
it's on somebody else that's just how
you're wired i'm doing everything i can
you you put me on the chiefs we're in
the super bowl you put me on the
buccaneers we're in the super bowl you
put me on this team this team this team
we're better than we are right now and i
think that the great quarterbacks can
say that honestly and truthfully that
they're doing everything they can to win
but there's 21 other guys between the
starting offense and defense that are on
the field that may not be good enough
and we're going to see i believe more
quarterbacks pushing for more power
in the cities where they currently play
and if they don't get it they're going
to be pushing to get out of the place
where they are and we've seen this come
up with receivers running backs
other position players on both sides of
the ball they want out jamal adams you
want out you want out you know it's
easier to say to a guy who isn't a
quarterback who wants out you got a
contract it's hard to say it to a
quarterback the minute the quarterback
decides he's not going to be that boss
on the shop floor that he's not going to
put in all those extra hours that he's
not as invested as he's been in the past
that he's going to take and i hate to
pick on matthew stafford but he's the
embodiment of this concept if they're
going to become matthew stafford and say
i just work here well good luck winning
games then
yeah and mike i talked to somebody
within the texans organization today and
they're still intent on they're not
trading deshaun watson well this is
going to come to a head because deshaun
watson is intent on not playing for the
texans so it's going to be interesting
to see how that plays out and these
quarterbacks the few the handful have a
lot of power and they're now using that
power to get what they want
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports